Hello Freak bitches.
Oh,
I bet.
Comicview frys three times.
Yeah,
so I mean like who was hosting the first
one ever was lester barry who was a
black circuit comic
for the very religious.
Nice.
The second time I did it was Arnez J in
Miami and the third time third time was
funny because I said by this point I go,
I'm not doing comic view ever again.
Like I just,
I've written that one off,
I'm not doing it.
It's always an awkward
situation when I go there too.
Why?
Because I'm the only white guy.
The production is white and they put some
weird responsibility on me to be like
the den mother of the comics,
so I've like smoked cigarettes and
I'd go outside and smoke a cigarette.
She was okay,
wait a second.
Who's everyone?
Jay's going to smoke if you want to smoke,
go out now with him and everyone's
got to be back in here in 15 minutes.
And then she tried to get me all of their
food tickets so I'd be responsible for
them.
It was very bizarre.
Just because you're white.
Yeah,
I mean I assume so.
That said,
a lot of the black comics will do things
like I'm gonna go out and smoke and
then go like,
you know,
fuck a chick for five hours trying to
come back 15 minutes for the show starts
like that did happen.
Well,
what they want you to do is just hang
out all day waiting for this show to
start.
Oh,
they put you there at nine
in the morning until night.
I went on at midnight.
What?
Yeah,
because they just don't want this wrangle
everybody because they don't believe
anyone.
No belief they're going to stay there.
They've done entire shows
about how happy they are.
Like they'll do a show where the same
joke gets repeated by different comedians.
Well,
yeah.
And,
and so I went and did it.
Kevin Hart ended up hosting,
I think one of the last ever seasons,
but it was called one mic stand and or
something like that I think is what it's
called,
one mic stand.
But it wasn't called comic view.
And Kevin called me and asked me if I
wanted to do it or if I would do it.
And I said,
yeah,
but I don't want it to comic view anymore.
He goes,
it's not common for you.
It's different.
They're flying people out now
they're doing it all right.
And set it up good.
And it was a,
when I signed the contract,
gets comic view presents one Mike Stand.
They gave us a big speech before we
taped anything and the guy was like,
we're changing comic view,
it's going to be different.
And the guys specifically said no more
stool humping and dj hit it and pulling
out fake teeth.
And uh,
I mean we weren't three comics in
before a guy was wearing fake teeth and
fucking a stool.
I mean not even about weight when
he's giving this speech to it,
these same guys who were getting ready
to fuck stools and put in fake teeth are
doing like,
you know,
like staring at him,
give the speech and like
nodding their heads like a,
like Pachino speech in any given Sunday.
It's a good emotional,
powerful speech.
How we're changing comic view now.
And then they went and
put the and they're like,
yeah,
let's go out there and
show the world something.
And then two minutes later you're like,
Dj put that Shit back on,
you can fuck a bitch with
fake teeth to this one.
No,
I couldn't agree more about DMT and,
and the,
the opening that it can give.
I
mean,
I had the great advantage of taking it
for the first time with Terence Mckenna.
And he said,
do you want to check this arch or.
Okay.
Um,
and that's pretty cool in a resume,
by the way,
first time you did DMT,
Terence Mckenna?
Yes.
I won't say where or when,
because it could be put down on some
record somewhere that's probably already
there.
Don't worry about it.
Um,
but um,
for me,
it correspondent in many ways with what
people talk about near death experiences
because I went out through light into
a realm of great bliss and beauty.
And then I came back and it was like
coming back from a million miles away and
just coming back into my body
and as it were being born again.
So it was,
it was very much like a death
and rebirth experience for me.
And,
and,
um,
it was very,
very transformative.
Incidentally,
I think,
you know,
I've been trying to understand this
American phenomenon with southern Baptists
and one of the things that I think is
the key to this is that I think when they
talk about being born again,
originally baptism was just that.
I mean now you can get this
through dmt in five minutes,
but at the time of John The baptist,
you get it in five minutes
through being drowned.
People were lining up on
the bank of the Jordan.
They go in,
he holds them under.
If he held him under just long enough,
you could actually induce
a near death experience.
No life review at the drowning man sees
his life pass before him hold the amount
of just long enough.
And they'd have a near death
experience almost guaranteed.
I mean,
occasionally they might,
he might have done it too long,
but that was before litigation.
You know,
you might have litigation.
Yeah.
Good theory actually.
And then you see,
they come back and they said,
I've died.
I've seen the light,
I'd been born again.
I'm no longer afraid of death.
My life has been transformed in five
minutes and the baptists were the people
who revived baptism by total immersion
in the 16th century and probably know in
America we don't hold them under that
long because this is post litigation.
Uh,
but you know,
when,
when the Baptist first got going,
this idea of holding
people aren't long enough.
All their language is the language
that relates to near death experiences.
And I don't think that to start with
baptism by total immersion was just
symbolic.
I think it was drowning.
What's needed is,
is transparency.
What's needed is up.
Do you think the transparency is going
to be an eventuality because of the
Internet,
do you think?
Learning?
Yeah,
I think it is right.
I think gets blown wide open.
It's very difficult to keep secrets and
it also erodes faith in the leadership
when like,
is this a democracy?
Is this a representative government or
is it some sort of a weird dictatorship?
Because if it is a hello fuck,
are you keeping that guy locked up?
How,
how is Julian assange still locked up?
Because I need to know.
Please tell me what exactly he did that
you need to export him to the United
States.
Oh,
he released some information,
which is our information to citizens.
This is not,
you know,
information that should be
kept secret from a king.
It's relationship.
It's,
it's information that someone who
was being paid with taxpayer dollars.
I did a bunch of shit that the
United States doesn't agree with.
Everyone was upset by the
information that was released.
Everyone was upset by that video.
The collateral murder video.
Everyone was obsessed by this massive
amount of data that showed there was a lot
of coercion,
a lot of lies,
a lot of,
lot of stuff that we don't agree with.
And because of that,
this guy's like public enemy number one.
Yeah.
That's,
that's so anti what we think
of as the United States.
Completely contrary to everything in the
United States stands for complainant on
that.
And so in answer to your question,
I would say yes,
it is some kind of weird dictatorship
posturing and posing as a,
as a democracy.
Because for,
for democracy to be real,
you have to have complete
openness of information.
People must be told the truth.
Then they can vote and make
decisions on the basis of facts.
What we actually have in our
society is the continual,
very clever massaging and
management of information.
So it ceases to be democracy.
When the voting,
when the voting public are fed,
lies on the basis of which they,
they make their decisions and vote
that that isn't democracy anymore.
That is in a way democracies are the
worst kind of dictatorship because they
have this appearance of freedom,
have this illusion of freedom.
And everybody can say,
well,
it's great because I live in a,
in a democracy,
at least.
If you live in a dictatorship,
you know you live in a dictatorship and
there are certain parameters that you
have to work your way round.
But when you live in a dictatorship
that is posing as a democracy,
it's more complicated.